- One, two, three, go!
Hi! Welcome to a new episode of Project Kamp!
In this video, you will see us harvesting some potatoes
with our very direct neighbors.
Because, this is our land...
And, this is Antonio's and Fernanda's land.
They asked us for some help.
Afterwards, we will also harvest our veggie box.
And, we will explain to you a bit more on why we do that.
And, this year, we have been visited
by a lot of wild animals.
And, at the end, you will see a very, very, very cute visit,
that we had from some friends.
I hope you enjoy it!
- So, what is the plan for now, guys?
We are going to harvest some potatoes,
to help out Fernanda and Antonio, our closest neighbors.
Ready?
- Ready!
Okay, so, harvesting potatoes on Fernanda's
and Antonio's field goes like this:
You choose either to dig, or to pick.
If you choose to dig...
You take the hoe, hit the soil
exactly at the edge of the water ditch...
Make it loose, and search for the little tasty gems.
Then, you throw them behind you, and repeat.
You need to dig hard enough to go deep.
But, at the same time, gentle and precise.
Otherwise, you will damage or cut the potatoes in half...
Which will be then followed by a less happy Antonio/Fernanda...
Who then gives you a private lesson on how to work properly.
If you choose to pick, it's easier.
You just throw the fresh, harvested potatoes in the bucket,
and for damaged and two small ones in another.
Nevertheless, you're going to be exhausted anyway,
since it's a huge field, it's super hot...
The potatoes don't come out of the soil by themselves!
- Did you understand what he said?
Just the good potatoes!
The next step is simple!
Hop on Antonio's tractor, and take a ride to the tiny house,
where they store the potatoes.
Don't forget to enjoy the lovely Portuguese countryside!
The right is short,
but be careful to not fall off the tractor.
Since the road is quite bumpy,
and you are sitting on the side of a giant shovel...
Then, hop up, empty the buckets,
and start again from the beginning.
If you made it to this point, congratulations!
You have passed the neighborly potato test!
You can see yourself now
as a true Portuguese neighbor.
And, you will be rewarded soon,
with a typical Portuguese boucher!
A delicious snack, which in our case is
crispy sardines, local cheese, bread...
Fried, and sweet flour balls...
And, three bottles of tasty homemade wine.
- Fernanda is asking if you're making a video!
Yes!
So, today we are here at Nunu and Sarah's place.
They are friends and they are also farmers.
They are usually the ones,
that bring a veggie box to us.
Which we showed in a video last season!
You might remember them!
Today, it's different.
Today, we come here to their place
to harvest our box.
This is why we want to explain
slightly why we are doing this.
So, Sarah and Nuno are part of a network of farmers,
which is called CSA.
That stands for 'Community Supported Agriculture'.
And, that stands for also creating a link,
between farmers and consumers.
So, that it's like a shared responsibility
between risks and rewards.
Because, being a small farmer, it involves a lot of risks.
In the sense of that they are dependent on a lot of variables,
that are beyond their hands...
Such as whether, as water supply,
as actually health and strength in their body.
This is actually the case on why we are here,
because Nuno got sick...
It means that Sarah is not able
to take care of the garden and harvest.
Also, to make the boxes and distribute it all by herself.
So, we as consumers come here,
and harvest the box ourselves.
- I've tried to seed some carrots on the side!
Come on through!
- Zucchini?
Yeah! Come on down here!
Yellow courgettes!
Either you twist it, or you can use a knife.
Courgettes are surprisingly spiky!
You have to take a yellow one back as well!
Oh, my God!
These are really nice!
I harvested this line...
- Okay, so, what's going to happen now?
So, now part of the mission is to harvest
some of the delicious, super big strawberries.
Look at this guy over here!
- That's pretty perfect!
So, maybe it would be easier for you guys,
to understand what actually CSA means.
Sarah will answer a few questions.
Maybe you could say why you chose to become part of CSA?
So, yeah, Community Supported Agriculture is interesting
for both us and the clients.
From our point of view, and from any farmer that's doing CSA,
it's interesting, because you have a certain security.
It's subscription-based, so it's easier to plan your farm.
You have that sort of base income that you can
sort of rely on, and at least near to long term.
It also means that with the box kind of products,
we can diversify in our farm.
Which is not only good for the environment,
but it also means that makes us more resilient.
Things like crop failures or strange weather,
which is happening more and more.
You know, one product might suffer,
but then we still have other stuff, that we can put in the boxes.
For the communities of the people who buy the boxes,
it's interesting, because it's more local.
So, your food will be fresher by a ton.
And, actually, the quality of the food is often better.
Not just because of the farming techniques, but...
Nowadays, products can be harvested before they're ready.
So that they travel better!
That sort of has a negative effect,
on the nutrients and vitamins that you find in your food.
So, it's healthy for you too!
And, it reduces food mass!
Does that answer your question?
- You answered like three questions I had!
Okay, perfect!
- It's benificial for you!
You had it prepared!
Maybe one more question is this:
''Are there any downsides of being part of this CSA?''
Sometimes, it can be a little bit challenging,
to get the planning right.
So, quantities, so, you know, you got to have enough
diversity in the food box, but also enough of quantities.
That makes sense.
That, with time, is getting better a lot,
because it was more difficult in the first year.
So, yeah, practice makes perfect!
- Cool, Sarah! Thank you!
That's it for the interview,
and I think we can continue with the harvest!
If you're happy, I am happy!
So, yesterday, we harvested really beautiful veggies,
for an incredible diverse basket.
Which I wanted to show you now!
There are a few things missing, like the strawberries.
They were too delicious to wait for today.
But, I just want you to see this richness
in colors, nutrients and flavors!
We got potatoes, we got fresh garlic...
We got a lot of aromatics, edible flowers, cabbage, kohlrabi...
Zucchini in different colors!
Some basil...
Yeah, summer is coming
And, with summer, a lot of diversity is coming.
Within the scheme of CSA, as we explained a little bit...
When something is missing, they replace it with something else.
In this case: yesterday, we didn't get lettuce.
So, we got extra beans, which sounds like a very cool deal.
We get this box once a week, which is a big luxury for us!
And, yeah, this is it!
For now, I just take the box back,
so that Agnes can do her magic.
They fell into the water!
- Really?
They could be, because they followed Otis!
Last week, we got visited by some new cute neighbors.
It seems they live close by in the mountains, because they just followed
Otis and Debbie, where they worked on the yoga deck.
The mom and dad were also there,
but they got scared by Otis and ran away!
For some reason, the puppies didn't.
We played a bit with them and then brought them back to the mountains,
where the parents were able to find them.
It worked fine with the two of them.
We also saw them with the mother,
but the little fellow with the white paws came back to us a few times.
We called him Brutus first, then Johnny, then Fling-Flong.
He really seems to like us!
But yeah, we still tried to bring him back to his mother,
so we said goodbye to him.
Let's see if it was for the last time!
That's it for this video!
I hope you guys enjoyed this episode!
If you like what we do in Project Kamp,
you can also support us on Patreon!
You will actually see our videos one week ahead.
You can also vote for our thumbnail!
Next week, we will do a review on our electric chainsaw.
For today, we have so many potatoes and I need to cut some...